you mentioned sovereign wealth funds and
i think a lot of folks have been paying
attention to what el salvador is doing
there's plenty of rumors about other
countries do you want to tell us which
sovereign wealth funds or what their
thought process is well you know el
salvador you know i have mixed emotions
in some ways because what i think
is important
is the ethos
of permissionless
right that anybody can join but i don't
force you to join what makes crypto in
general but bitcoin specifically so cool
it's now a nation state of 140 mil
million people that's the eighth largest
country on earth
uh think about that and that's people
from all over say i want to join and so
when you make it legal tenor you're
forcing people to use it i i'm
that that cuts the cost cuts against i
think the ethos
uh i know people will disagree with me
on that and it's it's good for adoption
but i don't
i don't buy into that
that side
i am seeing
sovereign wealth funds saying hey part
of my reserves
right it used to be the dollar and the
euro and gold
you're going to see a new bucket of
reserves across the world the dollar
will still be part of it but it'll be a
lesser part of it and it will be a
hodgepodge of things i'm sure crypto
will be part of it i'm sure bitcoin will
be part of it uh and that's just
starting and it's mostly starting and
these guys wanted to get into mining
uh
mining is an easier way for people to
think because everyone thinks they're
going to get in sheep
hey you did you like this video great we
make 5 of them a day and post them here
on this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time